you explain what is having smooth muscle antibodies. So when you have antibodies to self tissue,
that's an autoimmune disease. So smooth muscle antibodies, I don't know, I have to research that
a little bit, but any type of autoimmune disease means that you have antibodies to self tissue.
If you have antibodies to self tissue, then you, you're in a totally different ball of wax
is how you should be treating yourself from a nutritional dietary protocol. I'd highly recommend
not that I just want to push a product, but I'd highly recommend you spend $50
and join our autoimmune course. Because there's, so once you have self antibodies, if you're
going to be taking immune stimulants because anytime you are, so if you're any what naturally
minded, you might be taking immune stimulants because especially during, you know, the recent COVID
thing, a lot of people were taking immune stimulants. If those people had self antibodies,
many people found out that they had an autoimmune disease because that was a certain time of their
life that they started taking a lot of immune stimulants and they felt worse. If you have self antibodies,
antibodies to self tissue, when you're going to take products that are immune direct immune stimulants,
you're going to kill that which you have antibodies against first, which is going to be self tissue.
So if you have antibodies to smooth muscle tissue, you're going to end up with problems. Smooth muscles
lie in your arteries, you're going to end up with issues with blood pressure, you're going to end up
with, you know, so smooth muscles lie in other things too, but your biggest thing as far as symptom
pattern is going to be arterial, so it's going to have blood pressure issues. So you you want to
be careful, that's why I highly suggest that people when they have, you know, serious health issues
that they run antibody tests. So typically if we do a case review and a person has had health issues
for a period of time, they've been to multiple doctors, nobody's ever done an antibody test. We need
to find out, do you have self antibodies? Because you could be completely treating this wrong. A lot of
guys people will say, I think you have limes, so we're going to give you cat's claw and blah, blah, blah.
And they're giving them these things. And the person's continuing to get sick and the doctor will say,
no, you're just having a hurt side of a reaction, you need to work through this. This is a good thing.
It's not a good thing. So if you're stimulating immune system function and you have self antibodies,
antibodies to your tissue, you're going to feel worse because you're going to have more destruction
of whatever you have antibodies against. So for the $50 to learn how to look at autoimmune disease
the right way, it's a small investment. Certainly you can do a case review with me too, but if you know
that you have self antibodies, you know, you have an autoimmune disease, spend the 50 bucks on that
course and start working through it. You'll have a ton of aha molots and then you can make a case
review, set up a case review with me and we can go over, you know, different possible treatment parameters.